Why are you DMing random married women
in order to pretend to be a teenager
who's getting by a babysitter? That's
freak. Uh they've done weird roleplay
involving like teenage. But e even if
we're not friends, that still makes me
sad. It still makes me sad that he lied
right to my face.
So, if you guys missed it, Counterpoints
had a stream today and he was talking to
Dubbie and then I think eventually
Destiny hops on. Duby will make a point
of, okay, well, when Destiny docks his
people, he's putting people's family at
risks and he's like creating what we
would call a permission structure or a a
possible lens by which people will judge
him and act against him, right? That
while we principally don't, he is sort
of losing his moral high ground to say
people should defend me against these
these kinds of actions, right? Well,
THEY THINK THAT YOU USE YOUR SEXUAL
power and clout and influence and money
in order to mentally women.
>> Give me what example.
>> Annavore. So, so hold on. You think
Jtock Queen esports Batman, they all
hate you for delusional or non-serious
reasons?
>> Yes.
>> Uh I
>> Okay,
>> that's crazy.
>> Okay, dude.
>> Because you are reaping what you've
seown. You are reaping what you've seown
and you haven't learned your lesson and
it sucks.
>> Okay. In my current court case drama,
who what is the what what is the stone
part? What did I sew here? Or was it
immoral?
>> It wasn't immoral for you to have sex
with Pixie. It was immoral for you to
take her homemade insight into it to
somebody that you'd only known for 10
days.
>> Are you going to tell me how to run my
personal life?
>> No. But if anybody was your friend, they
would call you an idiot to your face,
which is what I'm doing right now. You
are an idiot. You are dumb. You ruin
your own life. I see my friend who's a
idiot up and I've tried to be nice about
it and that's not working. So, I'm going
to be mean about it. You don't know how
to manage your relationships. Anytime
anybody challenges you on anything, even
if they love you, you run away because
you're afraid of growing up. BUT YOU ARE
SUCH a that it is impossible to be your
friend. It's impossible to be your
partner. It is impossible to tell you
that you're wrong. It's impossible for
you to take a L. The future the future
of Counterpoints Politics. I think we're
going to cover his opening monologue.
What he'll do for his opening monologue
here. We'll cover that and then
uh from there I'm not totally sure where
we go. So I'm not I'm not going to be
slowly but surely burning all my bridges
for my uh you know snarkers
entertainment.
I just had a lot of frustration in
regards to the way that Steven was
conducting himself. I I said it
privately.
He threw his weight around on Friday. I
resented him throwing his weight around.
I told him I wasn't going to comply
unless he had evidence of what he was
alleging. He got upsetty spaghetti. I
got upsetty spaghetti. And then the next
day, uh, he wanted to talk again. And
truth be told, I didn't think it was a
good idea for us to talk. We probably
shouldn't have talked if we wanted to
maintain our friendship. We probably
should have let it go. But I'm also not
going to back down if you're going to be
throwing your weight around. So, um, I
told him that's the funny thing is all
of these people are like, "Connor, why
didn't you keep it private? Connor, why
didn't you keep it private?" Connor
didn't want to go on that stream. Connor
said he was going to sleep. A bunch of
people messaged Connor and said, "Oh,
hey, Destiny's like gonna come into
Melting Pot. We're going to all have
this conversation. Why don't you Why
don't you come and talk to us? Why don't
you come talk to us, Conor? Come and
talk to Destiny, Connor. He wanted to go
off. He wanted to go offline."
What had been bugging me for a really
long time. It like you you guys
understand like I'm really not trying to
be a [__] here, but it was a bitter
pill for me to swallow when uh what was
it? So Chudlo Logic and the Snarkers,
the commentary community, it was
actually Queman's fault. I I'll blame
Quman right now. Food Chops was a
nobody. No, nobody knew who Food Chops
was. Nobody cared who Food Chop was.
Food Chops was. She was probably getting
10 to 20 live viewers, you know, which
is
>> This is not true. Connor way overplays
this. Connor is just Connor is
histrionic right now.
>> Well, especially when you're like, I'm
not trying to dog the streaming. That's
not what I'm talking [__] about. I'm not
talking [__] about the streaming. But
then what happened was Queman cut
>> I'll be real Quan was a with 20 viewers
back here when he was talking to food
shops. Okay, what are we talking about?
>> Lolowed
her to 50 live viewers. Okay, so I was
like why even if we're lull cowing them,
why are we covering them sufficiently
that you're creating a community around
her? Then uh she basically says
everything that she says where she's
like a open defender of uh I felt like
commentary and Chud were going soft on
her because they they thought that there
was a uh an entertainment aspect to
keeping her around which I also kind of
found cruel like like they're they're
milking her while also providing her a
platform. And then uh she off for a year
and I was like okay that's that's great
you know like I don't think we should
have an outandout con just as a part of
Twitch and YouTube politics and as a
part of the community and then a year
later um maybe a year and a half later
she did go on like a whole crusade and I
will say again that is what we made the
counterpoints
Valor Media seal of approval for was to
point out that hey Connor you seem like
a little you seem like a bit of a
hypocrite here. You were talking about
how food shops people were break like
massively blowing up food shops and how
that was wrong to do and now you're
hanging out with Destiny who is
massively blowing up food chops cuz
apparently a 60 IQ was the only person
who will step forward and spew the lies
Destiny asked them asks them to spew.
Why is that the case? Why do we feel
like that's the case?
Right? Why won't an intelligent and
wellput together, you know, articulate
person come out and defend destiny?
There are zero people doing that, by the
way. There are zero people who are
informed of the facts, intelligent,
articulate, and will come out and defend
destiny. Not so Erdite says they're
friends or had said they were friends.
There's a reason she will not go
anywhere near this guy in a professional
sense right now, right? Like she wants
nothing to do with this guy in a
professional sense. It's very obvious.
He just continues to crash out. Mr.
Mootin and Dan do, but uh honestly I I
don't understand why
for Dan. Dan's got like all this other
stuff going on. I actually don't get it.
I really don't get it with Dan. With
with Mr. Mootin, I don't think he's got
a lot else going on. So
>> he becomes like Destiny's strongest
soldier after the debate. And then,
>> oh, also I do think that for Dan and
Mutton, they are not they like just
don't want to look into the facts. You
know what I mean? They Yeah, they just
don't want to look
>> during the summer. I'm like, "Hey,
Destiny, my friend, my brother in
Muhammad, peace be upon him. Maybe like
you shouldn't have
as your your primary litigant of your
drama." And he's like, "Nah, nah,
>> okay. What am I supposed to do with
that? Because if I freak out and attack
her, then I'm giving her more attention.
If I freak out and attack Steven, then
I'm not I'm not going to get the desire
I want because he's always the doubling
and tripling down kind of guy. So, if I
go scorched earth over that topic, he's
going to triple down on it. So, maybe I
can just back off a little bit and
gently push him in the background. But,
there was no there was nowhere to
>> Dude, there's, by the way, there are
like there's like a VC in that melting
pot server last night. I was listening
to it off and on while I was in a VC
with some other people and
like the Destiny Defenders are just low
IQ. They are just like incredibly stupid
people. It's really sad.
Like there there is nobody intelligent
who's on that side who isn't just like
motivated by something else. Like there
there could possibly be like some smart
people who are like sort of adjacent but
they don't know the facts and they they
kind of distance like like I'm telling
you Hutch is like a world beater IQ in
this universe right now. Hutch is like
far more intelligent than the average
person there right now. Okay.
>> Okay, Arthur. I don't know in which
direction you mean that, but whatever.
Um Okay. So, that that that was one of
the things that was stuck in my piece of
popcorn stuck in my teeth. And then the
other piece of popcorn that was stuck in
my teeth. I think I told you guys this,
but I'll tell you now in a more calm
manner, is that uh Britt and well
actually her husband DM'd me first. I
got I got a mention on Twitter. I'm
going to narrativeize this because to my
recollection, this is exactly what
happened.
I got a DM or I got an at on Twitter.
Hey, Destiny is ruining my life and
ruining my family and no one will talk
about it at four creators who are
Destiny's uh orbiters. And so I'm not
the kind of guy to, you know, basically
like ignore problems. you know, maybe
I'll minimize my problems, maybe I'll
attack my problems, maybe I'll criticize
my problems, but I'm not the kind of
person to ignore my problems. So, I I
like, okay, let's take this into the
DMs. So, we go into DMs and uh Devil
Devil basically tells me, and
unfortunately, this is on a suspended
account, but I guarantee you like
somewhere in my uh pictures, I have the
screenshots of the conversations that
are relevant. He basically says, "Hey,
I'm married. I'm a political dissident.
I guess if you don't want to call him a
groper and
>> political dissident. Okay.
>> He basically says, "Hey, I'm married.
I'm a political dissident." I guess if
you don't want to call him a groper, and
Destiny has been my wife for almost a
year. Uh they've done weird roleplay
involving like teenage. And by by the
way, I don't want to exaggerate. Uh, so
so I'm not going to exaggerate based off
of what I understand. Um, it wasn't like
a
diddling thing. It was like a teenage
babysitter roleplay thing. Okay. But
still, like it's weird, dude. You're
you're 40. You're 40. Like like get Why
are you DMing random married women in
order to pretend to be a teenager who's
getting by a babysitter? That's freak,
right?
Um, and that there's going to be some
dead
>> I Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. We
all We all knew about that. Is Is Connor
saying he he couldn't keep this, you
know, he couldn't keep this out of the
limelight cuz it's the exact same thing
as the Rose DMs? That seems odd.
Weird. Okay. All right. All right. very
odd
>> there for a second because I think I'm
gonna pull this up
>> because I think it's important because I
sent this message basically knowing it
looks like it looks like Destiny blocked
me, unblocked me, and then reblocked me.
Uh, I'm just going to I'm just going to
read I'm not reading his side of the
messages. I'm going to I'm going to read
exactly what I said. I sent this so
maybe I even found out about it earlier.
I might have found out about it in
November because I sent this on November
22nd of 2025.
I said, "Dearest Steven, I value our
friendship and want to continue it, but
you are." A traditional Catholic man
messaged me on Twitter saying that you
had sexed his wife as recently as
February. He wants to blow this up into
drama. The wife,
Dear Steven,
why would you write it like that? Just
seems odd to me. Right up right off rip,
you know, off rip. Dear Steven the
>> value our friendship and want to
continue it but you are a traditional
Catholic man messaged me on Twitter
saying that you had his wife as recently
as February. He wants to blow this up
into drama. The wife wanted to stay
quiet. His wife is actually a fan of
mine and contacted me as well saying she
was on the rocks with her husband and
that she was the initi initiator
involuntary participant in the however
she also said that you knew that she was
married in a psychological mess and
encouraged her to stop messaging. That
being said, you guys continued. She
mentioned that the messaging was quote
unquote spicy. And I inquired as to what
that spice was and found out. You are of
course
>> spicy. E, it was spicy.
Very spicy. Okay. And then he looked
into it.
>> Not just that, but she mentioned your
ex-girlfriend Leilana found the messages
and was angry with both of you. Her fear
was that Leilana may have taken
screenshots and may leak them out of
revenge if this all blows up. She was
arguing with her husband and in an
argument admitted to the messages. The
husband as a traditional Catholic, his
honor is insulted and he wants to
destroy you. To my knowledge, he does
not have copies of these messages.
However, this brings me to our
friendship.
>> Okay, so Connor is doing some background
investigating. He's talking to these
people and they're concerned that
Destiny's ex apparently would have
screenshotted some messages so that she
could share them with people and to blow
them up. I guess
>> I think you are intelligent,
charismatic, funny, Why would why would
any of this blow him up? The only thing
that would be getting leaked here is
that he was doing the exact same thing
he was doing with Rose. So why would any
of this have blown anything up? None of
this makes any sense whatsoever.
Like there is literally that doesn't
make any sense that people are like very
concerned because Destiny wanted to
pretend he was a little boy getting
babysat. That is out in the open. That's
been out in the open for a long time.
torically gifted man and I respect and
admire you and your talents. However, I
think you're a self-destructive
degenerate who has to constantly test
the loyalty of your friends. Conscious
or not, you engage in indefensible
behavior and look to see who sticks
around. In my opinion, you walk the
straight and narrow and then get bored
every few months, so you blow everything
up around to see who sticks around. It's
a self-fulfilling.
>> That's true. That's definitely true that
like there's something there going on. I
mean, I think it's just the low empathy
thing, right? The low empathy, like low
self-control, low impulse control thing,
right? He just he just enjoys it. Like,
he's just very much enjoying going
through the emotions of this. I think he
probably enjoys it as well with all of
these people being attached
professionally. I know for a fact I went
on a rant like talking towards talking
to Connor and not so Aerodite on not
directly but of course just to myself on
a stream where I explained don't just
understand that you've seen this pattern
unfold that everybody attached to
Destiny has had their lives blown up by
this guy like being incapable of
maintaining any sense of decorum any
sense of like normal behavior like every
single he will blow it up again and you
are basically using your reputations to
bolster his and he will blow you up for
it. Like you will not get consideration
from him. He will not consider you when
he takes risky like when he makes risky
decisions, right? He will blow you up.
He does not care. He does not think
about you guys. He has no concern for
you in his head whatsoever.
And I said this, it's got to be in March
or something of 2025.
And here it is again. Another example of
Destiny taking one of these risks, doing
one of these things.
Uh, isn't this because it's post his Oh,
I'm better now that I'm on Vance arc.
Oh, advanced basics. Welcome back to the
Starking team. I didn't even think about
that. Yes, I I forgot he no long.
Oh, that's beautiful. I didn't even
think about that. That we're post
Viveance. were posts like I don't engage
in these risky behaviors anymore because
I'm on Viveance now. Oh my god, that is
good. Yes.
Like I I knew this because I didn't ever
take the Viveance thing seriously. It's
just funny to have yet another lie
that's so obvious, right? Like to me it
just shows how bad his word is. Like how
his word is just worth nothing.
That's the that's the funny thing to me.
You act in such a way that any sane
person concerned with your reputation
would betray you out of a sense of
self-preservation. I sent that in
November 22nd of 2025.
Tell me how that is not exactly what has
happened. You're milking this a bit too
much. Don't you think? If Connor were
literally reporting Destiny to the FBI
and announcing that on stream, I know
this man's a which is not happening by
the way. I'm just using an example. It
it wouldn't matter to these people. They
would still be in here going, "Isn't it
a little weird to like be that
interested in what he's doing with his
>> Have you ever heard of like verbal
catharsis?
>> Are you like Are you like just really
obsessed with this?"
>> I'm literally getting out what's in my
brain.
>> Yikes. Why leak this? This is like a
really bad look for you. This is like a
really weird bad look for you. You're
like obsessed with this guy's You like
And you're backstabbing him over this
really.
>> So it doesn't choke me. So no offense to
Houseion. If if I say, "Hey, I got some
to say." And then you go, "This isn't
healthy. Don't say it." I'm going to get
pissed off. I'm going to get resentful
and I'm going to might even time you
out, bro. I'm not I'm not having Destiny
sympathetic people. Leaking private info
is one of the reasons why Hutch will not
collab with you moving forward. Okay. Be
a if you want.
>> Wait, what was that?
>> I might even time you out, bro. I'm not
I'm not having Destiny. Oh, leaking
private info is one reason Hutch will
likely not collab with you moving
forward.
>> Sympathetic.
>> Christian Valaris, this I believe is a
like was a mod on his channel was one of
his main guys, wasn't it? Christian
>> people leaking private info is one of
the reasons why Hutch will not collab
with you moving forward. Okay, him be a
if you want,
>> dude. Probably not help.
>> That's another thing, man.
So, what would happen is there would be
secret.
There would be a secret,
you know, um, in 2022, Lauren would say,
"Oh, yeah, Destiny and I aren't dating,
but we're really close friends and he's
helping me through my divorce, but don't
tell anyone. Don't tell anyone that I'm
divorced. Don't tell anyone that I'm
that I'm close friends with Steven."
Okay. No. Like, like, I shouldn't have
kept that to myself. I shouldn't I I
should have told her you you need to go
public. Same thing with um same thing
with Destiny. Destiny would be like,
"Oh, you know, um you know, like this
situation with the with the with the
traditional Catholic man." I would find
out about that and I would say, "Hey,
man. This is pretty up." And then he go,
"I'm not I'm not keeping any more
secrets. There's no more secrets.
You tell me something that'sed up and
somebody asks me about it, I'm telling
them. I'm not I'm not sweeping for your
>> You know what? We're gonna we're going
to turn this over. We're gonna keep
Connor in frame as best we can, but
we're going to get onto the chat here
because this is kind of important.
>> Why? Why go public?
>> Because it's destroying their lives.
That's why the secrets are destroying
their lives. That's why I don't have any
secrets. You know why I don't have any
secrets? Because I conduct myself in
public the way that I conduct myself in
private. The only sins that I have, the
only sins of lying that I've ever done
are sins of lies of omission. Meaning
somebody asked me a question that was
inconvenient for a friend of mine. So I
pretended that I didn't know the answer
to the question. I said, "Oh, I don't
know about that. I might have to
research that a little bit."
>> Dude, people think like depending on
what you're omitting, a lie of omission
is really bad, right?
It's It's Man,
it's tough.
I can't believe he just admitted that
straight up, though. That's That's a
little
>> But I'm not doing that anymore. It's not
happening. I'm not sweeping for anybody
else's secrets. I'm not keeping my own
secrets. You ask me, I tell you. That's
the relationship. And by the way, if
that's Hutch's problem, oh, Connor
leaked a bunch of personal, okay? I
don't trust Connor. Good. Don't trust
me. Don't trust me. Don't don't don't
come up to me like, let's say Hutch
relapsed, but he wanted to keep it a
secret. Oh, hey Connor, we're internet
friends, right? I want you to know that
I started doing heroin again, but you
know, I got it under control.
No. Somebody says, "Hey, Hutch has been
a little bit loopy recently. Is he on?"
I'm gonna go. Yeah. Yeah, he's on, dude.
Uh, holy, let me say, let me Oh my
goodness. Um, dude, they're going to
blow. They're going to be so mad about
that. They're going to be so angry about
that.
No, no, no. He's joking. He's saying
that if Hutch came to him and said that,
he would not lie about it. He's done
lying by omission. That if you ask him
something, he's done lying by omission.
Let's see. Uh, dude,
>> leaked a bunch of personal. Okay. I
don't trust Connor. Good. Don't trust
me. Okay. It's done. It's done. I'm not
doing it. Everyone lies. Don't. No, I
don't. No, I don't. I act as though my
actions on this plane of existence are
make me accountable to the creator of
the universe. And when I die, I'll be
judged. That could be mythological. That
that could be metaphorical. For all I
know, I'm dying and I'm going straight
in the dirt. It'll be like mindless
oblivion. But I'm going to act as though
I'm accountable to the creator of the
universe. And that involves not lying.
So I'm not going to lie. Your yourself
for even insinuating that everybody
routinely commits lies of commissions.
You're piece of [__] Why did Officer
Nasty's comment get deleted for saying
Connor's always had this position for
years. Why is that getting deleted?
You're over moderating.
You are over moderating. What would your
drill instructor say? Wait, why?
Dude, dude, that's crazy. Officer Nasty
says Conor's had this position for years
and then apparently gets deleted.
Bro, that's a that's crazy, man. That's
This is Oh, man. This is rough.
>> My drill instructor would say,
>> it's rough watching this happen to
another person.
>> Courage, commitment. He would say,
conduct yourself in an honorable way in
public. He would say, have the bravery
to do what's right when you think it's
right. Have the commitment to stand by
your principles. That's what my drill
instructor would say. What's uh JJ did
tiebuckle? JJ did tiebuckle. It's like
justice, judgment, dependability,
initiative, decisiveness, tact,
integrity.
I forget the other ones. Your leadership
principles. Uh let me take a look.
>> They're deleting support for Connor. It
was that's like
listen, my community wasn't like that
because of how things broke up. But I do
think like eventually I just noticed
there's like still people like this in
my community who will like defend stuff
reflexively. Like oh man
like defend defend Desty stuff like
reflexively before they have any
conversation on it. And I I get the
feeling that Connor is going to have to
suffer through that for a while. Like
it's just like how do you talk about it
other than in the framing of like a cult
or brainwashing? Because it's like these
people don't have a reason or any logic
to why they do what they do. They don't
think about it. They just do it. It's
like reflexive for them. It's it's crazy
to watch and see just see it happen over
and over and over again.
>> Let me let me tell tell you what they
would do. My drill instructor would say,
"Remember your leadership principles.
Justice. Steven is conducting himself in
an unjust way. Judgment. Being able to
discern what's happening in a situation.
I'm using my judgment. Dependability.
I'm wildly dependable as long as you
don't want to make me carry your
initiative. I'm always initiating.
Decisiveness. I make decisions and I
stick by them. Tact. I have no tact.
Integrity. I try to have integrity in so
far as I am okay with what I am and I am
what I am. Enthusiasm. I am wildly
enthusiastic about my job. Bearing. I do
have excellent bearing. Unselfishness.
I'm not very selfish. courage. I try to
do what's right regardless of whether or
not it's hard. Knowledge. I think I have
decent knowledge. Loyalty. I think I
demonstrated that I have pretty strong
loyalty. And from my perspective, I'm
still being loyal to Steven. He's my
friend. He's up. I'm not I'm not going
to stand by and be part of his
self-destruction. So, if he wants to end
our friendship, then so be it. And
endurance. I have the endurance in order
to endure
whiny ass ders in my chat.
So, why does your uh Twitter account
keep getting banned? Because I keep
using homophobic and abbleist slurs.
>> Cool. That's That's nice. Conor's just
taking personal responsibility there.
Very cool.
>> But no offense, when you're being uh
when you're being affeminite and weak
and you're not thinking, I'm going to
call you homophobic and abbleist slurs.
>> Connor, always liked you. It's too bad
the friendship ended like this, but life
goes on. I think the reason I subscribed
to you initially was because every time
I saw you on a debate panels, you
dominated
>> make the content. But if you come in
here like
No,
no,
no.
I'm I'm going to freak the [__] out on
you. that
>> there's like this pattern that man I
should come up with a better way of
describing it but essentially what
happens with Destiny is a more evolved
and stronger version of what happens
with techone or sorry yeah what happens
with techone like Destiny's just better
at it this perpetual self victimization
that happens you slowly filter down to
the most loyal people who are the most
exploitable the most like like you just
always paint yourself as the victim over
and over and over again. And you always
will find people, especially if you have
a big a big platform, you will always
find people who are willing to help you
and try to pick you back up. And you
have to do no work. It's like a method
to succeed while doing no work of your
own. Okay? You could just consistently
paint yourself as the biggest victim
possible over and over and over again.
And people who are like, it's the exact
kind of person that would like prop up
an addict through some addictive
behavior, right? that would keep helping
them even though they keep like keep
descending, keep like um you know making
massive mistakes in their life because
of their addiction, but somebody just
keeps you know coming in and holding
them up. Chibi Strat. Yeah, Chibi and
Techone are way way way worse at it than
Destiny is. Destiny is so much better at
it than anybody else.
And and dude, I love this phrase so
much. He he uses this phrase so much. I
don't want to paint myself as a victim,
but I I shouldn't be painting I hate I
hate I hate being like acting like a
victim, but dude, he uses this phrase so
much.
It's crazy.
>> Chill the out.
>> So anyway, all all suffice to say, I
think Connor got taken advantage of
here. And I think that explains why the
entire cult sort of comes and lines up
behind him, especially when they
perceive him as persecuted for some
reason. like everybody lines up behind
him because right now it's like the
snarkers. He's painted all these
villains. It's a it ties into why he has
to do villains only. Why he doesn't have
like a like maybe he did the Israel
thing. Could the Israel thing have been
like a positive direction for his
channel at some point? But otherwise,
it's all setting up villains that he
needs to take down that he's being like
held down and persecuted by every single
time because again, he is the victim.
He's like the internet's biggest martyr.
If people would just stop attacking him
and and trying to hurt him for no
reason, then eventually
eventually
he'll save democracy. But it's just
every all these bad actors are holding
him down and preventing him from being
successful. It's very
and you start to see why it develops
into this cultlike thing, right? Like
basically if you are saying something
negative about destiny this is the
mindset of all of them is essentially
they think democracy can be saved as
long as people would stop treating this
guy unfairly and so they attack right
they attack attack attack anybody who
says something negative about him
because that is in itself if you have a
negative opinion of Destiny it's like
evil uh Wick talked to Destiny for 5
minutes and came in to an agreement you
could have done the same
but Wick Wick literally
Wick literally changed his discord
policy and refused to enforce his
Discord policy, right? People in
Destiny's community were recording his
Discord. He refused to enforce that
policy or and he changed the policy
because of what Destiny was asking,
right? He didn't kick Doobie, but he
gave up like basically the privacy of
his discorders and that's why people
were mad
>> in your chat, but you still, you know, I
would appreciate it if you moderated him
heavily, but you know, at least kick him
out of the Discord because I don't want
him uh conducting gay ops in order to
convert people away, you know, into like
haters of mine. If he had come to me on
a personal level and said that, I
probably would have been like, "Okay,
six years of relationship, you're
uncomfortable with something, you're
expressing it like a man, you're making
a direct ask, you know, you're not
trying to strongarm me with your
position." I probably would have agreed
to it, but that's not what he did. He
like came on while I was describing what
I felt was an implicit threat
and uh Mutton said, "Yep, that's the
implicit threat. if you don't get rid of
these people, then we're we're gonna
[__] we're we're not gonna associate
with it you anymore. You can go [__]
yourself. And so
>> we're taking our business elsewhere.
>> As a result, I was like, "Oh, okay. You
right. You want me to kick out Doobie?
You want me to kick out Officer Nasty?
Show me evidence that they're doxing,
swatting, or harassing people because
talking
about people on the internet is not a
crime. I talk about people on the
internet. Destiny talks about people on
the internet. Every creator and every
fan of this space talks about people on
the internet.
>> So if you want me to ban these people
because they are your malicious digital
harassers who are engaged in a prolonged
digital terrorist campaign, you need to
show me evidence. And when I asked him
for evidence and I confronted him about
the fact that he doxed two people
without good cause, he freaked the out.
And I I'm not I'm not going to do that.
I'm not going to do that. And another
thing another thing that I'll tell you
that I'm uh Death Lily, I'm sorry,
Connor, you chose to stream the
conversation. You could have done it to
it privately. I already did uh earlier.
Connor one chose to chose to have the
conversation a place where multiple
people could have streamed it. I believe
multiple people did stream it. By the
way, Destiny asked to talk to Connor in
a place he knew would be streamed. That
was not on Connor. I'm sorry. Stop
blaming Connor. That is not on Connor.
Destiny asked to have that conversation
in a streamable VC where multiple people
streamed it. You cannot say Connor
streamed it. It's his fault. shut the
up.
>> In November, I I read a direct like for
Saturday's conversation
for Saturday's conversation. I did have
a private conversation with him and he's
the one making the ask. Why didn't he
take it privately?
He's the one who wanted to join the
stream. I told him what I want or like I
articulated what I wanted out of the
situation perfectly all day. Why didn't
he take it to DMs? Why is it my
responsibility when my friend of six
years is implicitly threatening me? Why
is it my job to take it to DMs? That's
not my job. And he knew what he was
doing. He obviously knew what he was
doing. Wait, is Connor an anti-fan now?
It's a welltrodden path. No,
I don't even see it here. Too bad.
>> I'm not going to dedicate the next two
years of my content to hating Destiny. I
don't care that much. I still like
Destiny, you idiots.
I really I really wish that Destiny was
a better person, but he's not. And he's
an
a part of his downfall.
So, I'm not. No. No. I don't hate
Destiny. Lord and I, we text every few
months. We're we're we're not close
close, but we're friendly. Okay. So,
I am getting divorced. I tell Lauren
about it. I tell Stephen about it and
then I'm kind of thinking like I'm gonna
be single. I don't want to be single,
but who who can I date? Because I
actually I enjoy partnership. I enjoy
having a good friend, right? What was
the lie? Don't worry, I'll tell you
momentarily.
>> So, I actually go to school
>> first. I don't even know that Stephen
and Lauren are dating. Okay. I do not
know that Lauren and Steven are dating.
Okay.
>> Okay. And you haven't shown any proof,
fatty. I don't need to. I know what the
truth is. See you. So, I go to Steven
first.
Okay. He said that I asked Lauren out. I
never asked Lauren out. I went to Steven
and I said, "Hey,
I know that you dated Lauren in the
past. Lauren's a cool girl. Would you
care if I asked her out?" And he said,
"No, I don't care. Go for it."
That's what he said to me. Okay. Then
I'm just talking to Lauren as a friend
and I maybe it gets back to her from
Stephen like, "Hey, Connor's thinking
about asking you out or whatever." And
then Lauren says, "Oh, no. Um, so so
hey, Stephen and I we're thinking about
seeing each other again." I don't know
if they ever physically saw each other
again. I don't know if they ever
dated again. I have no idea what their
actual relationship is. I have no idea.
But she said, "Hey, I'm talking to
Stephen again. Um, you know, I I want to
see where that goes." I didn't ask her
out. Okay. I didn't ask her out. She
didn't ask me out. She didn't say no. I
just never asked her out. Were they back
together this year? Maybe. I don't know.
They were at least talking. They were at
least talking as friends and exploring
the possibility of getting back
together, right?
I hope they're still secretly dating.
Me, too. But I don't think that's the
case.
So, what ended up happening was maybe a
month ago,
maybe a few weeks ago,
they I I'll try to keep this as clean as
I can without like leaking too much
details, but basically, I get word back
that Lauren wanted a commitment
and Steven was unable to commit. I think
that's vague.
>> Uh I do believe this as well, right?
It's it's pretty clear to me that the
reason Lauren was so quick to point that
out is because Destiny, again, super
cool friend, by the way, probably
messaged her immediately about it. Yeah.
Like, don't you just go,
why would Dude, if you're a real friend,
don't you just go, it would actually
make me uncomfortable if you I didn't
even listen to Desty's response. I was
sending a DM. But why would you just say
that makes me uncomfortable actually? So
if you wouldn't, that would be cool,
right? You don't want to tell him that
you're dating, but if you say that, it
gets the same outcome assuming Connor is
willing to honor that given that he's
asking you in the first place anyway,
right?
>> Anyway,
>> to not hurt anybody.
>> Okay. Lauren wanted a commitment. Steven
wouldn't commit. It's that simple. Okay.
And so this is where Steven lies.
This is where he lies to my face. He
lies to your face.
Okay.
He said, "Oh, Connor, number one, you
don't have a wife." Okay. I was married
for 15 years. What's your longest
relationship? How long was Steven with
Molina? Three. I've dated people longer
than Steven's been was with Molina. So,
okay, that's not very impressive to me.
You I was with one person for 15 years.
That's an achievement to me. Just
because it didn't work out in the long
term doesn't mean that I'm not proud of
what I did in reference to my wife. So,
he goes, "Lol, you don't even have a
wife anymore, right? How many wow
friends do you have left?" And then he
says, "Uh, I have more friends than you
have wives." Right? That's what he said.
Which, by the way, the only thing
Destiny can say concretely about how
many friends he has is
more than zero. That's That's where he
was willing to set the bar. I'm pretty
sure I got at least one.
So, that's funny. It's a good jab. It's
a good jab. But then he says, "Uh,
Stephen," or I say, "Uh, you know,
Lauren wanted to get back with you. you
know, um that she wants what's best for
you, that she cares about you, that she
loves you, but you're such a
you can't you can't accept friendship,
you can't let anybody get close to you,
you can't be a good partner, you can't
do this, you can't do that because
you're such a
and you can't take an L. And so Steven
says,
uh, how about this L? Lauren and I have
been secretly dating for three months.
He didn't know that I knew that they
were already broken up. So tell me, I'm
getting criticized
about being, you know, a bad friend. I
feel like I'm calling out my friend on
his
and I'm telling him that he's a By the
way, this is like the only way they
could think about this, too. Like the
idea that somehow this only I I do I
truly believe this only works on like
the the most like deprived of human
contact people in the world.
Like somehow, and dude, it's going to
sound like I'm defending myself here,
but somehow there's like this super evil
bad thing if two people who originally
talked to Destiny like start talking or
hooking up in some way. Like Destiny's
tried to say basically all of his old
friends were hooking up with each other.
It's like, well, they have all the same
interests and they're all in the same
community. That's probably just going to
happen. And somehow this has led to
people backstabbing Destiny. I don't
even know how that could possibly be the
case, right?
But it it only works on like the people
who don't have like if you've never been
in that situation before where you meet
somebody at work or through college or
wherever and you realize that oh
everybody who hangs out with each other,
you know, a certain number of hours a
day, something eventually happens there
or there's something preventing it,
right? Like somebody's in a monogous
relationship already. It's like super
obvious.
Destiny hates Rey now just for dating
Jasmine. I it would be man you'd have to
be a uniquely like evil person to hate
all relevant to be honest with you. Like
the only people who would say they hate
irrelevant are snarker types who don't
like him but they have to say they hate
him because they're too edgy and and
hyperbolic, right? That's the those are
the only people who could possibly say
they hate irrelevant. There's just
nothing to hate about him. Sorry.
And as if to prove my point, there's a
bunch of people here. There's a bunch of
people in the chat getting ready to Oh,
also I don't have any evidence that they
dated at all. Cringle Ganesh, I don't
have the I don't have any evidence for
that. So, I would have to somebody would
have to show me evidence of them dating.
Do you know what I mean? Anyway,
okay. So, yeah. Anyway, they
apparently Connor couldn't possibly just
be annoyed with Destiny had doing some
self-destructive behavior. It had to be
out of like jealousy over Lauren
Southern. I don't know. I don't know.
I It's just goofy to me.
>> How should I take it that Stephen when
he's getting pressed
and he feels like he's in a corner,
he's willing to willfully lie
in order to make his opponent look worse
and in order to make himself look
better. How should I feel about my
friend?
Because I'll tell you the way I feel
about my friend. I feel like I can't
trust him. I can't trust him going like
like obviously he's lied to other people
and I've seen him get caught in his
lies, but I've I've actually never
caught him in a lie.
Oh, that's that also gets rough when you
like start to see how obviously this guy
lies to everybody. How he will like
Destiny I truly think, you know, when he
he's talked about like cheating and
stuff and how it's like only bad if the
other person finds out. He truly
believes deep in his heart of hearts
that a lie is not bad unless people
catch you on it. Like it's totally
normal. He is a pathological liar. He
will lie about everything always until
like it's pointed out and he can be held
to it. That's when it becomes something
he has to talk about or care about.
Right?
Like this is specifically the one I
always think about the most is when he's
like three or four months after leaking
the Pixie tape that he's being sued for,
right? Or one of the Pixie tapes he's
being sued for, I should say.
He
he says in his chat during the Mr. Girl
the end of the Mr. Girl stuff, I I have
the cleanest DMs everywhere. I've never
done anything like wrong. You could
check all of my DMs, I'd never be
caught. It's it's like um it's the same
thing as the method Josh thing, right?
The whole like people don't really think
I'm crazy or people think I'm really
crazy and then they sort of get
normalized and then eventually they
realize I actually am that crazy.
Yeah, it's it's that
I I have never caught Destiny in a lie.
He said some crazy that I kind of gave
him an eyebrow on. He did not say that.
Laugh my ass off. Yes, he did. Yes, he
did. He said, "You want to L? Lauren and
I have been secretly dating for the past
three months." That's what he said. And
he was wrong. He was lying.
I
have seen Steven be hyperbolic.
I've seen him try to destroy the public
reputations of his enemies. I've even
arguably seen him caught in like a lie
that could be argued to be like, you
know, kind of like a funible like like a
like like a weird, you know, bending of
the truth. But he's never lied to me.
Okay. He He's never said, "Hey, Connor,
here's something that I know to be
untrue,
and I'm going to say it to you in order
to obtain a benefit."
That's never happened. At least not
directly to me. I'm sure it's happened
to other people, but it's never
happened.
>> It happens all the time, Connor. It
literally happens all the time.
>> So, I'll just tell you right now,
>> I s I wish I knew this was Conor's red
line. If I'd known this was Conor's red
line, I could have provided him evidence
of this stuff happening. Like, oh, you
just want to know that he's like
basically lied to somebody close to him
and that it's provable. Like, it's a
provable lie that he knew was a lie at
the time. That's all you want?
>> Uh, like I said, I want Steven to do
well.
I want him to succeed in his career. I
want him to succeed in his personal
life. I want him to stabilize.
>> Let me check this time stamp.
>> I want him to be a fantastic
political commentator. I want him to do
beautiful analysis of current events,
news, and politics for him to become
ingratiated
with the
uh the Yeah. Unfortunately, he's kind of
falling apart, man. Like the all of the
stuff he does on like in a political
sense, it's all very embarrassing and
self- serving now. Like it it's sort of
just it seemed seemingly all falling
apart at this point in my opinion.
mainstream
and for him to become a wildly
successful political commentator. That's
what I hope for Steven. And I hope that
in his future relationships, while he
will probably still be promiscuous, I
hope that he is more careful not to hurt
mentally ill women. Okay, that that's
what I hope for Stephen and I earnestly
believe that.
But I am not. Even if we rekindled our
friendship, I would never be able to
fully trust him.
I would never be able to fully trust him
because in an opportunity where he was
getting pressed
>> with the truth,
>> he decided to lie to my face and to
probably 2 to 3,000 people in order to
make me look bad and to make him look
better by comparison.
So I will
>> Destiny jacket. never be able to fully
trust him again.
>> So, that's sad. I mean, we're probably
not going to be friends. Let's be real.
But, um but e even if we're not friends,
that still makes me sad. It still makes
me sad that he lied right to my face.